saint loup sur semouse est une ville
intrigante pleine de contrastes entre
maisons de maître et usine désaffectée
oui salou a connu un âge d'or grâce au
bois et aux meubles
[Musique]
la foire du meuble de salle ou sur
semouse vient de connaître trois jours
glorieux
une foire unique en son genre dans la
région puisqu'elle ne regroupe que des
fabricants et vendeurs de meubles son
importance économique elle dépasse
largement le cadre régional on peut dire
que c'est la plus importante foire du
meuble de l'est de la france elle
représente toute l'industrie locale vous
savez que nous avons ici les plus grande
usine de france de meubles et nous avons
un artisanat qui est très développée au
point de vue meublaient au point de vue
sculptures d'art
cette foire gérard galmiche l'actuel
président du comité d'organisation la
connaît bien
il y a participé pendant des années
comme vendeur d'électroménager
ça fait quoi comme effet je veux pas
pleurer je suis toujours là oui et je
peux vous dire quand même que j'ai vécu
une super année de fort esprit et on
prend de très bien c'était une grande
époque que j'ai une grande époque la
force de saint loup se déroule toujours
à la même date durant le week-end des
rameaux
une semaine avant pâques aujourd'hui on
a bien sûr du vote toujours
avant mai
surtout dans les magasins donc il nous a
fallu remplacer petit à petit ce qui est
exposé ses terres le mup autre chose on
compte sur les trois jours
dix mille entrées aux aussi ils ont fait
la foire comme ils disent
l'un était tapissier l'autre ébéniste il
visionne un reportage de fr3 le père de
jacques lagrange explique son métier
d'ébéniste voilà voilà papa dans son
domaine ce n'est beaucoup d'achats des
5es dans notre sens où il a passé des
heures sur sa planche à dessin passer
d'un film et du travail qui faisait un
petit peu l'autonomie c'est de
l'artisanat en n'ayant jamais jamais
sacrifié alors la productivité c'est
peut-être un petit peu ce qui nous a
fait disparaître ou six ans et même
table à dessin même atelier
mais les machines se sont tus jacques
lagrange a pris sa retraite il ya une
quinzaine d'années la mairie a racheté
locaux et machina on avait laissé
attaquer quelqu'un vous dit qu'il était
un petit peu plus poussive et bien sûr
noté la belle sortie ça nous permettrait
de remettre des jeunes qui voudraient
s'installer en mer de profiter de
disposer des machines and ateliers pour
les jeunes ce projet est encore à
l'étude
en revanche un autre a enfin vu le jour
le conservatoire m appelle l'ue et le
conservatoire du siège et du meuble a
été installé dans les anciens locaux des
usines réussi une entreprise fermée en
2013 donc tous ses sièges là il avait
retrouvé une bonne partie par tous parce
que j'ai malheureusement j'adore
quelques qui ont disparu par contre
toute la collection bambou on n'a pas
retrouvé pour l'instant présenté au
public les stocks qui était en réserve
et des prêts de particuliers et ça nous
c'était la cité du meuble donc ça a été
mais on veut aussi nous dire que le
passé ça sert aussi ponette pour
construire l'avenir j'espère que de
jeunes reprendront le flambeau et
referont des belles choses qui redorera
le blason de saloper du bas la famille
parizeau a confié cette salle à manger
art déco fabriqué à saint louvent
parisot fleuron de l'industrie du meuble
cette entreprise est la ville veulent
croire encore un avenir meilleur
[Musique]